it's an active investigation in terms of
a warm guy she was my friend
the only person that alec baldwin should
be speaking to is his lawyer
the day i arrived in santa fe to start
shooting i took her to dinner with joel
the director
alec was candid talking with the
paparazzi in vermont for three minutes
and 40 seconds i talked to the cops
every day
but was speaking out a smart move we
asked two experts media analyst joe
koncha and legal expert rachel stockman
if his comments could affect his case
prosecutors are considering whether or
not alec could be charged with a crime
to me it just seemed like a bit of a
chaotic situation we were a very very
excuse me
alec baldwin makes it hard to have
sympathy for him when he is hushing his
wife when he's being rude and dismissive
to his wife that was simply trying to
help him you guys you know what no
details
do me a favor i'm gonna answer the
question
considering he already has enough bad
press right now the fact that he
delivered this interview in this way i
don't think necessarily helps him
in the court of public opinion we're
eagerly awaiting for the sheriff's
department to tell us what their
investigation has yielded what else do
you have
i think it was alec baldwin's attempt to
get the paparazzi essentially off his
back i don't think his attorneys would
have said okay you can go ahead and
speak to them i felt like it was almost
a desperate move on his part but you met
with her family in the days yeah if
you're spending this much time waiting
for us
ellaria posted these halloween pics of
alec and their six kids and wrote
parenting through this has been an
intense experience to say the least
today we rallied to give them a holiday
free advice for alec baldwin maybe try
to get away to somewhere where the press
can't find you order in for a while and
wait for this to blow over in terms of
it being one of the top stories in our
news cycle do you think production will
start up again no i doubt it necessarily
sadly we're learning the final words
spoken by cinematographer helena
hutchins according to the la times after
the bullet hit her a crew member heard
helena say that was no good that was no
good at all we were a very very you know
well-oiled crew shooting a film together
and then this horrible event happened
[Music]